I am Morgan from Lee diplomat I'm here
with Rudy and Eli we're gonna be making
my cocktail today called libation
without representation representing the
wonderful District of Washington DC you
see a lot of state it's not a state not
a state I infused Bombay Sapphire with
fresh apples cherries and vanilla bean
let's sit for a week can you infuse
other things what can you infuse
absolutely you can infuse essentially
most food thing if you would eat it you
can infuse with it you can infuse with
bacon and could I just drink half the
Bombay and then fill it with with bacon
yes you can fill it with anything you'd
like like doughnuts doughnuts are a
little harder you wanted us start with
this pure of an ingredient local
scotches fresh ingredients typically
that's what I did for this so we're
gonna do an ounce and a half of that do
the small so take the small one the big
side big side so there's a little line
in there it's gonna be an ounce and a
half okay I believe I do
I'm leaking oh yeah oh that's so good
just drop it into this guy yep turn up
estimated honey syrup okay
50% honey 50% hot water but it just you
she was very easy so half an ounce of
that so the little guy although I photos
all the way for
and then half an ounce of lemon ease how
many drinks an hour do you think we
could make realistically like four you
could pour a lot of beers I've poured my
[ __ ] ton of beers add ice on there like
a panting dog this is always the hard
part for me hit it on the side with your
wrist I should say it doesn't ever hear
your haughtiness like six all it does
yeah so just hold the bottle
[ __ ] hit with your wrists oh my
god it only took the fifth time well if
you're holding it if you're holding the
bottom while you're trying to hit off
the bottom can be very good somebody
could have just explained that to me
like three cities yeah that's training
time to strain and draining out of them
and then we're going to top it with a
little champagne lutely co yellow label
okay if you can't pronounce that and we
want to buy something else at the store
is there anything else that would work
Aspen for champagne
that's not for champagne they got okay
let's try it good enough yeah there it
is all right what's the final step I am
garnishing it with a apple slice in the
shape of BB C flat good - we use is that
upside-down
okay so many things we're learning today
I'm scared to use those fingers there so
I don't know I can't handle it the
pressure plus I like teamwork oh look at
that I know what should we toast to you
to President Underwood
cheers Cheers that's fantastic oh you
should try ours to make sure we didn't
oh yeah yeah tell me the truth
don't lie yet a great teacher teacher no
they're good job guys oh very good
and that's the game nice job